more than a year after a deadly crash
Virgin Galactic is back to its mission
of exploring the solar system
well kinda Richard Branson's company is
really about sending wealthy tourists
into suborbital space and it's not
launching anybody just yet
but today it rolled out spaceship to
number two the key innovation in this
spacecraft designed by aerospace master
Burt Rutan is the system that folds the
tail up and down changing the ship's
position as it re-enters the atmosphere
during an October 2014 test flight the
first spaceship to broke apart in midair
after a pilot activated that system to
soon like its doomed predecessor the new
spaceship too will be carried into the
air by the double-hulled White Knight 2
at 50,000 feet spaceship 2 is released
fires its rocket and shoot straight up
and out of here the new spaceship 2
meant to carry paying customers works
the same way with a few design tweaks
the key difference is that the controls
have been changed so no one can repeat
that pilots deadly mistake ultimately
the idea is to carry passengers to 62
miles above the Earth's surface
giving them four minutes of
weightlessness and official astronauts
status
of course there's a whole lot of testing
to do before any passengers are welcome
aboard and now that Virgin Galactic
finally has a spaceship again it can get
back to making that happen